Ron you ask a very interesting question
in fact when I was in high school
I used to play with antimatter it turns
out the sodium 22 naturally emits
positrons are antielectrons I put the
antimatter inside a cloud chamber put it
into a 600 gasps magic field and clearly
the positrons were bending in the wrong
direction in a magnetic field meaning
that positive electrons were being
created in my cloud chamber later I
built an atom smasher in hopes of
getting a beam of antimatter
so antimatter has the opposite charge of
ordinary matter the antimatter that I
photographed in high school had a
positive charge electrons normally have
a negative charge so anti electrons can
circulate around anti protons and we do
this at cern outside geneva switzerland
and also at Fermilab outside chicago in
fact if you read the novel angels and
demons which is made into a movie
starring Tom Hanks the whole novel was
based upon building an antimatter bomb
that might be able to destroy the
Vatican so if I have antimatter and
according to the novel if I touch it
with ordinary matter I would have
complete annihilation meaning that the
efficiency of the bomb would be about a
hundred times greater than the
efficiency of a hydrogen bomb a hydrogen
bomb is only about 1% efficient an
antimatter bomb would be a hundred
percent efficient so anti-people
are also possible anti planets anti
galaxies are also possible but the
danger is that if the two touch each
other then they will annihilate into a
burst of energy however we've looked for
antimatter in the universe we've looked
everywhere for antimatter and we see
very little antimatter in the galaxy
there's a fountain of antimatter coming
out from the center of the Milky Way
galaxy in the direction of the
constellation Sagittarius however it's
very small and it leaves the mystery why
are we made out of matter and not
antimatter why don't we meet anti people
out there that's a big cosmological
question the leading theory is at the
beginning of the
universe at the Big Bang there were
almost equal amounts of matter and
antimatter the two annihilated in the
instant of the Big Bang and we are the
leftovers so everything you see around
us today we believe is a leftover from
the Titanic annihilation of matter and
antimatter at the beginning of the
universe itself